two three four and seven how do we find
the arithmetic mean and the median of
this set of numbers there is no pattern
in this set of numbers using the
traditional approach we can find the
mean with the formula sum of terms
divided by the number of terms the sum
of terms would be 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus 7
and the number of terms is 4 this will
be 16 divided by 4 which equals 4 the
arithmetic mean of these four numbers is
for the median will be the value in the
middle as we have even number of terms
the median will be the average of the
two terms in the middle the two numbers
in the middle are 3 and 4 the median
will be 3 plus 4 divided by 2 that will
be 7 divided by 2 which is 3.5 you can
see that the mean and the median are
different here can the mean and the
median be different for evenly spaced
numbers let's consider the number set 3
6 9 and 12 we have a fixed increment of
what is its arithmetic mean the sum of
terms is 9 plus 9 18 plus 12 which is 30
and the number of terms is 4 this gives
us 7.5 what about the median the number
of terms is even so the median will be
the average of the middle terms which is
6 plus 9 divided by 2 which also equals
7.5 both are equal and this will always
be true for a set of evenly spaced
numbers the arithmetic mean will always
be equal to the median this is a very
important concept for evenly spaced
numbers the arithmetic mean will always
be equal to
the median but four evenly spaced
numbers we have a better way to find
these two values look at the next set of
numbers the set ranges from 105 to 120
in fixed intervals of 3 we want to find
the arithmetic mean and the median of
this set we have seen that for evenly
spaced numbers the arithmetic mean is
equal to the median but using the
traditional technique of adding all
terms would be a pain here's the trick
for evenly spaced numbers both these
values will equal the average of the
first and the last term's it's as simple
as that first term plus the last term
divided by 2 it will be
105 plus 120 divided by 2 that will be
225 divided by 2 which equals 100 and
12.5 now wasn't that quick for any set
of evenly spaced numbers the arithmetic
mean and the median
both will equal to the average of the
first and the last term's
of that set and why is it quicker for
the mean we do not have to add up all
the numbers in the set and for the
median we did not have to figure out the
middle value we just need to use this
simple formula